[MUSIC PLAYING]
[WHOOSH]
[CLICK]
Hi, I'm Mano Marks.
And welcome to another Google
Maps Developer Shortcut.
Today, we're going to be talking
about earthquakes.
Earthquakes are something that
happens constantly around the
world, obviously.
And the US Geological Survey
gives out a JSON feed that
allows you to parse that data
and put it into your
applications so that you can
get notifications of
earthquakes as they're happening
around the world.
So I'm going to take you, first,
through a demo of this
application that I built, quick
app that I built using
Storyboards and
NSJSONSerialization, and then
walk you through a little
bit of the code.
So this is my app, here,
in the iOS Simulator.
You'll see here that I
have a Table View.
And I click on the Table View,
and it loads up the Google
Maps SDK for iOS and shows
you the location.
And if you click on the marker,
it'll actually show
you the title, which is the
location in plain text.
And there's a little
snippet under there
that says the magnitude.
All right, so what does this
look like in code?
Well, first, let's take a
look at the JSON feeds.
This is what it looks
like in the browser.
So this is just a data
serialization format.
But that's not really
easy to look at.
So let's just take a look
at what it looks
like in Sublime Text.
So you see here, each line
is an object in JSON.
Now, JSON is a format that's
very familiar to JavaScript
developers, and is becoming a
common data format for people
working in mobile applications,
as well, because
it's nice and compact
and easy to parse.
And a lot of operating systems,
including Android and
iOS, have developed native
libraries for parsing it out.
So basically, you're seeing here
a dictionary of objects.
This key-value pair is very
easy to sort through.
So let's just take a look
here in my code.
I defined an NSURL for
the URL for the feed.
So that's this
earthquakesusgsds.gov.
I'm choosing All Earthquakes
in the Last Hour.
And then, when the view does
load, it fetches the data.
So there's a fetchData
method here.
And I create two arrays,
quakeArray and markerArray.
And then, I do a dispatch_async,
which is just
a way to fetch data
from a URL.
And I assign it to a queue and
then say, create this NSData
object at the URL that
I've specified.
And then, when you're
done, go and run
the fetchedData method.
And so, in here, I've got
fetchedData method, which I've
passed in NSData.
And so what I do is I make
this quakeArray.
It initializes it with an
initial capacity of 100,
because I figure, hopefully,
not over 100 earthquakes in
the last hour all around
the planet.
And then, here's the
key piece here.
I created a JSON object using
NSJSONSerialization.
And then, I just say,
JSONObjectWithObect and
responseData, which
is the data that I
passed in to the method.
And that returns to me an object
that I can then just
parse through, looking
for keys.
It's a dictionary, basically,
that I can then parse through
and create other dictionaries
out of the different objects,
and then use that data
in my application.
So here you see, I'm just
going through the latest
Earthquakes object, which is
in this array, and then
creating dictionaries or parsing
out strings for each
of the different objects.
And then, what I do is I then
assign the array to the
tableView as the data source.
And I reload the table.
And then, because I'm
using a Storyboard--
and you can see my last
Shortcut on doing
storyboards--
I prepare for the Segue by
basically passing in an object
that then gets passed to the
next view controller, which is
EQViewController.
And that then parses out the
GMSCameraPosition from the
object and creates a marker
at that location.
So you can see that working with
JSON in Objective-C is
actually a very simple
process.
The key thing here is
NSJSONSerialization, which
provides you with some
native support.
And that allows you to use web
services in your application
and publish them like I did.
So that's all I've
got for today.
Thank you for coming
to our Shortcut.
And we'll see you next week.
[WHOOSH]
[CLICK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]